[Música]
hoje eu vou falar de como as tecnologias
podem ajudar a incluir pessoas com
deficiência física bem porque escolhi
esse tema em 2016 eu fui com os meus
pais para as paraolimpíadas e acabei
conhecendo esse tipo de deficiência e me
impressionei de como é as pessoas
conseguiram se superar em 2018 o meu pai
teve uma pequena lesão vai ter pra eu
tive a experiência temporária de cometer
um deficiente físico na família em 2019
minha mente é eu fui acompanhar a minha
mãe ao dentista ea dentista me disse que
eu estava com a perna quebrada e que um
dia ela teve que ir fazer compras mas
antes disso ela teve que pesquisar em
várias lojas para ver se tinha um
carrinho elétrico quando eu acho ela se
dirigiu até lá pegou um carrinho começou
a fazer as compras normalmente até que o
carrinho desligou sozinho já que estava
abastecido
isso prova que as pessoas não estão
muito preparados para atender esse tipo
de deficiência
mas não podemos deixar de citar um dos
maiores exemplos da tecnologia ajudando
sua eficiência como di stéfano hawks que
um famoso físico britânico que tinha um
problema neurológico generativo e morreu
em 2008
ele usava de várias tecnologias como por
exemplo a queda é como uma das mais
simples a cadeira de rodas
a cadeira de rodas foi feita pra atender
cadeirantes
a cadeira de rodas é uma das tecnologias
mais simples para atender os cadeirantes
mas antigamente era bem mais pesadas
confortável já hoje existem motorizadas
até com aparelhos modernos mas também
existem diversas outras tecnologias como
nós oculares próteses ou até mesmo a
temer
as coisas que lehto o exoesqueleto ajuda
pacientes que tenham sofrido pequenas
lesões vertebrais a recuperar até 7% do
gasto de energia para andar como por
exemplo esse esqueleto roda criado pela
empresa sai perdendo mas ou seja o que
podemos esperar para o futuro
podemos esperar que novas tecnologias se
desenvolvam para atender todas as
pessoas mas então o que podemos fazer no
presente
podemos desenvolver las ou simplesmente
comprá las já que vai ajudar a em as
empresas que fabricam obrigado pela sua
atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]